the marvel cinematic universe adds
another hero to its ranks in thor love
and thunder as jane foster transforms
into the mighty thor while battling
stage four cancer are fans ready to
discuss jane's fate and how does it
compare to the comics keep watching to
find out
let's bring the rainbow the
world-renowned astrophysicist hasn't
been seen in the present-day mcu aside
from a quick cameo in avengers end game
since thor the dark world and she's back
with a thunderous bang her new asgardian
powers are a shock to thor himself who
tries to look at his own place in the
cosmos in something of a midlife crisis
when speaking to fandango director taika
waititi revealed how he convinced
natalie portman to return noting that he
wanted to reinvent the role for the star
her character in those first few films
is probably not the most exciting
version of the female character we want
from these films i wanted to change that
character just like with changes
character for ragnarok and give her more
license to be adventurous and fun and
funny cause natalie's a really funny
person foster handles herself while in
the fight to gain score the god butcher
who's determined to slaughter all the
gods in the universe but she also has to
deal with the fact that as in the comics
using her powers it's effectively
stopping her chemotherapy from doing its
job it puts jane in an incredibly
difficult position because although she
wants to be there in the fight she has
to slow down because of her health
ultimately this leads to an incredibly
emotional finale for jane and thor one
that could lead to something more jane
unfortunately succumbs to her cancer in
the final battle because the energy she
uses to help thor fight gore drains her
strength thankfully her soul is taken up
to valhalla in the post-credits scene
because she died on the field of battle
a sign that she's a true hero obviously
it's a shame that she dies only one film
into her superhero career but it is a
worthy evolution for the talented
scientists but is it actually the end in
the jason aaron comics from which parts
of jane's story and thought love and
thunder were adapted the focus is on
jane's new identity but she does
eventually die from her cancer after
saving asgardia in mighty thor issue
706.
as she stands at the gates though odin
decides that her sacrifice is a feat of
true heroism and channels a cosmic
thunderstorm to resurrect her a
superhero resurrected from death in
comics surely not so yes it's entirely
possible that jane might return to the
mcu from valhalla in a future film
whether she should come back from the
dead is another question entirely
because this wraps up her storyline
nicely while honoring what makes jane
great as a person but marvel always lays
the groundwork for the future and the
valhalla post credit scene isn't there
for nothing where could jane's story in
the mcu go next though and what are the
chances that portman returns to the role
you might think that after dealing with
stage four cancer taking on the powers
of a norse god and dying valiantly in
battle only to be revived again by odin
himself jane foster might be ready to
call it quits on a superhero career
however in the world of marvel comics
the character continues to play a
noteworthy role in the action she pops
up throughout the war of the realms arc
and even assumes the mantle of a
valkyrie in the aftermath of the bloody
interdimensional battle although the mcu
has obviously been forging its own path
through the marvel canon using the
comics as inspiration rather than
doctrine jane's robust and continuing
story on the page certainly leaves the
door wide open for her return down the
road the character's buddy buddy
friendship with king valkyrie and thor
love and thunder could be one such
conduit for a return especially
considering jane's transformation into
one of the norse fairy women in her
comics arc of course she only becomes a
valkyrie after the others are killed so
if the relationship between the two
characters does bring jane back to the
mcu it could end in tragedy but we're
getting ahead of ourselves as far as any
future live-action appearances from jane
are concerned the real deciding factor
will most likely be whether natalie
portman is interested in doing another
mcu film after stepping away from the
franchise following 2013 saw the dark
world taika waititi helped convince
portman to return for love and thunder
by breathing new life into the character
of jane foster perhaps with another
juicy storyline portman could be
convinced to return again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
thought love and thunder are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]